[Music]
on this thursday night the canadian
armed forces
in crisis it really has been a big shock
for everyone in uniform
the dual investigations into canada's
new top soldier
and his predecessor plus multiplying
allegations
about sexual misconduct in the military
you're bending over to untie your boot
and then someone grabs your butt
broken promises how ottawa is failing to
investigate international human rights
abuse complaints
linked to canadian companies and utterly
dissatisfied the texture has changed the
cold hard facts
about our butter and why dairy farmers
are not laughing
we have nothing to
[Music]
global hide with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
there is intense turmoil at the highest
ranks of the canadian military tonight
after global news broke the story about
allegations of sexual misconduct against
the former chief of the defense staff
the man appointed to replace him has
also stepped aside
and he is also under investigation
general jonathan vance stepped down in
january as chief of the defense staff
after announcing his retirement last
year admiral art mcdonald
took over and now just six weeks later
he's also
stepped aside pending an investigation
the reason has not been made public
the cbc is reporting mcdonald is also
being investigated for suspected
sexual misconduct we have complete
coverage tonight from mercedes stevenson
and david aiken in our ottawa bureau
david let's begin with you
well donna we start with a middle of the
night bombshell
involving canada's highest ranking
military officer
and that has plunged the canadian forces
into a crisis
uncharted territory and a real body blow
to the department of national defense
and the canadian armed forces i mean
these
are this is really i think a crisis for
our military it was well known
that this type of misconduct was
happening within the ranks from
running from bottom to top admiral art
mcdonald's decision to
voluntarily step aside was announced in
a statement published by the military
after 11 pm eastern wednesday
no official explanation for mcdonald's
decision was provided but
in the house of commons thursday the
deputy prime minister had
this to say every woman in canada should
be able to do her job
free of harassment the canadian forces
national investigation
service has confirmed an investigation
into
admiral mcdonald mcdonald who has made
no comment on the matter is a decorated
naval officer
who had only been chief of the defense
staff for two months
replacing general jonathan vance who
served nearly
40 years in the canadian army vance is
under investigation
for allegations of inappropriate sexual
conduct
towards two female subordinates vance
denies the allegations
what's disappointing is when the chain
of command
is either part of the problem or the
chain of command doesn't have the
opportunity to do
the right thing because they don't know
about the the issues themselves
people need to realize that it's bigger
than just the issue of
sexual misconduct it's an issue of um
shifting culture
it's an issue of power imbalance and
it's
we need to take a water lens if we
really want to make any changes
and that's going to make any difference
in the meantime lieutenant general wayne
eyre will become the acting chief of the
defense staff
ayer is a saskatchewan native who joined
the military in 1988 and
he will not be unfamiliar to the chain
of command in this country
and among our allies you know you really
just can't understate or underplay
how disruptive something like this is
for our defense relations with the rest
of the world and the defense of canada
now as for any further allegations the
government today insisting
all allegations will be independently
investigated
regardless of the rank of the individual
involved
donna all right david aiken thanks when
two of the top leaders in the military
are under investigation what does that
say
about the organization itself our ottawa
bureau chief mercedes stevenson broke
the story about the allegations against
general vance
mercedes you have lots of contacts
within the military what are you hearing
tonight
donna literally getting dozens and
dozens of emails a day about this but in
particular the last 24 hours
have stunned and shocked people even
people who believed and had said that
they thought
that sexual misconduct was potentially
endemic at senior levels of the canadian
forces
still stunned to see a second chief of
the defense staff
now under investigation by the cfnis the
military police
a lot of people describing this to me as
feeling like a reckoning in the canadian
forces as a moment when they will
finally confront what operation honor
was supposed to have achieved
six years ago but many many women have
told me
that they don't feel that way and to
give you a sense of some of what i'm
hearing i'm getting emails saying the
truth matters
i too am a survivor of military sexual
assault
finally at the time i wondered what i
had done
from one man who was kicked out of the
canadian forces who says i was forced
out for less
so you're really hearing people saying
they feel that this is a moment when the
canadian forces has to confront this
problem
that they believe was happening with
commanding officers and at the senior
ranks
we spoke to one woman who is a survivor
of military sexual trauma
she told us what her experience was like
a guy here
a guy there you know you don't do
something one guy wants and then all of
a sudden you become a target
you're really unsure of what to do you
don't know who you can and can't talk to
so you kind of just put up with it for a
long time
it's demoralizing it scares you
and the main thing we're hearing donna
is really that people have taken courage
from what major kelly brennan said to
global news and her willingness to speak
out and put her name and face on it
mercedes this is such a shakeup at the
most senior level what happens now how
does the military fix this
well essentially a lot of folks are
saying cultural change that it can't
just be talking the talk it has to be
walking the walk and that means those
top
officers can't be saying one thing and
doing another
and on top of that they are looking at
everyone
this has been described to me as a drag
net that they are going to go through
and try to find out
who there's allegations against and
pursue those in a way that has not been
done before
donna all right mercedes stevenson in
ottawa thank you
sexual misconduct in the military is not
limited to canada
in the u.s a female member of the u.s
marine corps has posted a raw and
distressing video on tick tock
she describes how she felt when she
found out the marine found guilty of
mistreating her was allowed to remain in
uniform
to admit what he did and they say okay
well you were really good at your job
and yeah you did a bad thing
but we're gonna we're gonna make sure
that you get out honorably
she says her name is dalina and that she
reported a
for sexual misconduct in 2019 in
december 2020 she says she was told her
alleged attacker would be honorably
discharged
last week she learned he is staying put
this is exactly why females in the
military
kill themselves the marine corps
responded
with a statement confirming the man was
found guilty and that the final actions
in the administrative separation process
are ongoing it says it takes any
allegations seriously
and provides the required assistance to
any and all victims
it is worth noting the man found guilty
in that case also served as a victim
advocate tasked with supporting sexual
assault
survivors in other news it is an
important day in alberta the premier
says the province has been sideswiped by
what he calls a
triple black swan of the global
recession the collapse in energy prices
and the pandemic
not long ago alberta's finance minister
tabled his latest budget the province
forecasts an
18.2 billion dollar deficit the
government is setting aside 1.25 billion
dollars in additional money for a covet
19 contingency fund and is increasing
health care spending by 900 million
dollars it also plans to invest another
1.7 billion
in funding to build infrastructure and
create jobs
heather urex west breaks down what this
all means for albertans
a briefing on budget 2020 a year after
tabling a budget that became
irrelevant almost as soon as it passed
alberta has laid out what it hopes is a
path towards recovery
budget 2021 was developed in response to
our challenges it's a plan that will see
alberta
past its current crisis by focusing on
what matters most
but it's a daunting road forward
alberta's deficit which ballooned from
seven to more than
20 billion dollars last year is budgeted
at more than
18 billion for the year ahead the
province says balancing the budget will
have to wait
resource revenue remains soft there are
no new taxes
and the province has increased spending
promising more money for capital
economic stimulus projects and the
pandemic response
there is also new investment in economic
diversification
it funds specific sector strategies such
as technology
tourism aviation aerospace and
pharmaceuticals
energy financial technology and
agriculture
the challenge of this budget is is to
try to
generate confidence not so much in jason
kennedy's leadership or even the
government but on
in the proposals the popularity of
alberta's premier has fallen sharply in
the last
12 months on top of challenges
associated with a drop in the global
demand for energy the government has
come under fire for its handling of the
covet 19 pandemic
a travel scandal while having to reverse
course on several
unpopular policies the government has
been in
a tailspin throughout much of 2021
budgets aren't a way out of it budgets
can make that worse
this year's deficit does not yet account
for the more than 1.2
billion dollars in losses associated
with the government's investment in the
now cancelled keystone xl pipeline
the province says it will focus on
reducing the deficit over the next
two years with spending cuts but beyond
that
new sources of revenue like taxes will
likely be needed to get to balance
in the years ahead heather urex west
global news calgary
there's some optimism in ontario that
public health restrictions and vaccines
are having an impact on reducing the
spread of covid19
though officials continue to warn the
new variants of concern could reverse
progress if people let their guard down
the latest modeling
reveals the recent decline in the seven
day average of new cases has leveled off
and
may be ticking back up in the likely
scenario variants will cause
daily case numbers the yellow line in
this graph to increase to around 2
000 per day by the end of next month and
in the worst case scenario in the
modeling
seen on this graph in purple nearly 4
000 new cases
every day the military commander leading
canada's vaccine distribution is
confident deliveries are now
back on track the federal government
says 1.3 million doses of the moderna
vaccine will be shipped in march
and more than 3.7 million doses of the
pfizer biontec vaccine
will be sent by april 15th
this next month alone we will receive
over 3 million doses
of the 6 million doses of both approved
vaccines
and in terms of those two approved
vaccines alone 23 million
in the in the april the june time frame
that's major general danny forte
he says provincial territorial and
federal governments are planning a
virtual exercise
on march 9th to go over how to handle
the increased vaccine deliveries
and there is an update tonight on the
numbers canada's public health agency
says one and a half million doses have
been administered so far
that means about 2.9 percent of
canadians have received one dose
well just over one percent have received
two doses
my goal was to get a hundred million
covert vaccine shots
in people's arms in my first hundred
days as president
and today i'm here to report we're
halfway there
50 million shots in just 37 days since
i've become president
that is american president joe biden
marking a vaccine milestone in that
country
he says the goal is to have enough doses
for every adult american
by the end of july cautious optimism
after a year of enduring the pandemic
coming up how more countries are
starting to crush the curve
this is quite the serenade from their
balconies fiji's rugby team sang a
beautiful thank you song to hotel staff
and security
after spending two weeks in quarantine
in sydney australia
quarantine is mandatory for all
international arrivals there
cautious optimism the worst of the
pandemic could be behind us
vaccine distribution is increasing
though there are still more than 100
countries who have not administered a
single dose
today pfizer announced it is doing a
small clinical trial of a third shot
a booster to determine if it protects
against the more contagious variants
those variants remain a wild card but as
eric sorensen reports overall
there are signs of hope for many
countries to look at israel
is to see the future a hopeful future
most israelis have now been vaccinated
not only has shopping opened up the
country is allowing activities like
live theater for those immunized there's
almost a giddiness around ordinary
activities
the life coming back
what can i say worldwide there is reason
for optimism
per capita globally covert 19 case
numbers peaked in january
and have fallen by about half in just
the last six weeks
in canada a similar trajectory over the
last year
the us the uk and israel saw their worst
numbers of the pandemic six weeks ago
and are now seeing a very steep drop off
and in those three countries
vaccines may be making a difference
studies in the uk and israel show a drop
in infections and hospitalizations
after immunizations in the groups that
have been vaccinated
their cases are dropping much quicker
than if they haven't been vaccinated so
clearly
on a small scale in most places vaccine
is having a role
vaccines add to many factors gradually
forcing the pandemic into submission
including lockdowns in individual habits
like distancing and masks
drugs and other treatments have reduced
the severity and population immunity
those who've had the virus and
increasingly those who've been
vaccinated
so we know that we're going to have
sufficient vaccine by the middle of this
year
so we're going to be done with this to a
large extent by the end of the year but
what about the new covid variants
they are bound to create a surge in
cases in the weeks ahead
in this country and others but experts
believe vaccines will still make a big
difference
even with variants we've seen that all
of the vaccines
are very good at decreasing severe
illness and death
that is a huge win on a public health
level and is still one of
our tickets out of the pandemic the uk
is also a leader in administering
vaccines
and starting next month restrictions
will be lifted in stages
a wretched year will give way to a
spring and a summer that will be very
different and incomparably better
the aim for full lockdowns to become a
thing of the past
i can't wait to be able to go out and
have little normality
be lovely and as more nations get
vaccinated what may spread now
is optimism eric sorensen global news
toronto
canadian companies accused of human
rights abuses overseas
still ahead are they being let off the
hook
rescue efforts are underway in indonesia
at this illegal gold mine
days of heavy rain triggered a landslide
trapping dozens of workers
more than a dozen have been rescued at
least six are dead and several others
are still missing
illegal mining operations are common in
indonesia
the federal government in canada is
scaling back one of its human rights
commitments the liberals promised to
create a watchdog to investigate
allegations linked to canadian companies
operating overseas
the office will soon be open but as
jasmine pizzano explains
it won't have all the powers needed to
properly look into complaints
including some serious allegations being
fired at one canadian mining company
it's a feeling of loss that passes every
year
claudiana dos santos says she lives
close to where canadian company yamana
mines for gold in the brazilian city of
jacobina
she claims that the dust from the mining
is making people sick
the most common occurrences were these
sinusitis
asthma shortness of breath foreign
plaintiffs have filed eight related
court claims in canada against canadian
extractive companies
none of those cases involve yamana but
some
find it difficult and expensive to
pursue justice through canadian courts
people who are impacted find that they
have nowhere to go
to seek help a real change
in 2015 the trudeau liberals promised to
create a watchdog
later called the corps to advise
canadian companies
and investigate complaints when needed
the liberal government later paid an
expert
who suggested the best way to ensure the
corps has the necessary powers would be
to create a law
but after years of industry lobbying the
government scaled back its plans for the
core
my office does not have the ability to
enforce
any of our recommendations in 2018 the
government said online that the corps
would be able to
compel witnesses and documents but today
it says she can review allegations and
provide advice to the government
having the ability to compel testimony
and documents
would you know put us in a enough the
most favorable
situation to be able to assess the facts
and to be able to come to
recommendations the office of the
international trade minister
mary ing said in a statement not
collaborating in good faith with the
corps can result in the withdrawal of
trade advocacy support
and the refusal of future support from
export development canada
canada should not be relying
only on voluntary responses
yamana told global news allegations in
jacobina were unsubstantiated
and that there's no detrimental impact
from this mine's operations
its human rights policy says yamana is
committed to protecting the health and
safety of all individuals affected by
its business activities
but dos santo says the mining has
transformed her community
and she's afraid generations to come
will never have the same memories that
she did
jasmine pizano global news toronto
next i can't believe it's not softer the
big butter debate
listen to what they're dealing with in
canada some canadians say they've
noticed butter
is harder than it was in the past when
you're stuck at home for almost a year
these are the things you start to notice
like
honey does the mustard seem more
mustardy
laughter about canadian butter is
spreading as fast as a bad pun
but there is a serious question about
what's going on and why
palm oil is ending up in a product that
comes from cows
ross lord reports now this butter's been
out for
24 hours and it still makes for tough
spreading
this nova scotia food researcher says
it's because canadian butter
has become thicker there are so many
people noticing the same
thing at the same time sylvan charlebois
suspects people are noticing the
difference because they're using more
butter
in the pandemic baking boom he blames
the chunkiness
on this palm oil and its extracts used
in dairy cattle feed
palm oil gets a bad name because
cultivating it destroys
rain forests the question i think is is
whether or not
it is ethically questionable given
the baggage that comes with palm oil the
controversy with the hashtag
buttergate has caused people to take
sides online
the canadian food inspection agency says
milk produced from a cow that's fed palm
oil is
safe suggesting it's not much different
than vegetable oil
but the dairy industry is backing off
the dairy farmers of canada says
after listening to concerns expressed by
consumers
it's asking farmers to consider
alternatives to palm supplements
while a working group studies the issue
we want to understand the science but at
the same time
we also want to you know exceed the
expectations of our consumers in canada
some farmers are reluctant when somebody
attacks the industry and how we feed our
cows to say that we're
we're hiding something is just you know
wrong we have we have nothing to hide
this nova scotia farm says
it includes just a tiny fraction of a
palm oil derivative in its feed rations
because it's rich in calories which make
for more productive cattle
my only ask is if we have to stop using
this product which i'm totally willing
to do
then the stuff the 20 percent that we
import darn well better be
held to the same standard charlevoix
says he's received
threats from dairy farmers over his
comments an issue that seemed innocuous
has turned out to be no laughing matter
ross lord
global news and that is global national
for this thursday i'm donna friesen
tonight's year canada
is the sunrise over northern bay
newfoundland and labrador
thanks for watching robin gill will be
here tomorrow and i'm back on saturday
with the new reality take care of
yourselves bye-bye
you